authorities are investigating whether
sabotage is the cause of leaks in the
Nordstrom gas pipelines connecting
Russia to Europe scientists recorded
explosions in the Baltic Sea before
detecting three simultaneous leaks
Ukraine's accused Russia of carrying out
a terror attack Germany Denmark and the
us all fear it could be sabotaged the
Kremlin says it's extremely concerned
about the leaks the pipeline operator
says that damage is unprecedented
gas bubbles churn the Baltic Sea this
video from Denmark's military shows one
area where 70 meters below sea level gas
is escaping from the nordstream
Pipelines
the undersea pipelines nordstream 1 and
2 Link Russia and Germany
three red dots Mark the places where
leaks were detected even though the
pipelines are not currently delivering
Russian gas to Europe there's still fuel
in the pipes
the pipeline's operator reported a drop
in pressure but researchers said they
had detected possible explosions in the
area where the leaks were observed well
the source of these explosions I mean I
mean as far as we can tell there's
nothing natural naturally occurring that
that could explain these the exact
source of them is is of course a bit
hard for us us to speculate about
um
if these really are explosions which we
find highly likely then of course
they're man-made somehow
Denmark's prime minister would not
exclude intentional damage to the pipes
we cannot rule it out it is too early to
draw conclusions
but this is an extraordinary situation
it is an unusual situation and there are
three leagues even with some distance
between them and that is why it's hard
to imagine that what's happening is a
coincidence
but her polish counterpart alleged that
the leaks are sabotaged after the
leaders toured an energy facility in
Poland the questions over the gas leaks
in the Baltic Sea highlight how
politicized energy supplies have become
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
the Kremlin says it wants to know what
caused the damage to
messages
no option can be ruled out right now
it's clear that there is damage to the
pipeline we can't exclude any version of
events regarding the reason for this
before the results of the official
investigation
it's an investigation that will be
closely watched by Russia and its
European Neighbors
let's watch it now with Benjamin Schmidt
he's a former European energy security
advisor at the U.S Department of State
and joins us from Cambridge
Massachusetts uh welcome back to DW Ben
what do you reckon um sabotage
unfortunately I think so Phil I think
that you know when we saw this let's go
over the timeline of the last 24 hours
the first Nordstrom 2 trunk line
remember each Nordstrom pipeline
consists of two trunk lines carrying
half the capacity each so the first of
the two nordstring two trunk lines uh
first had reports of a pressure drop
rapid depressurization and then uh
visibility of a leak basically bubbles
coming to the surface that was first uh
seen by uh a uh a Danish F-16 pilot on
patrol in the Baltic Sea
um so what that said to me immediately
was you know where did this take place
um and this took Place Southeast of born
home and this is notable because the
seabed southeast of born home was for a
long time objected to to have
construction life gets going on by all
many of the Baltic Sea uh literal states
that took place in the aspu convention
process that underscores the
environmental security risk because of
large-scale chemical and conventional
munition dumping sites in that region
that took place post-world War II so my
thought over last night maybe it's some
sort of uh um you know physical security
incident related to those dumping sites
that were long since uh warned about
since the very initiation of nordstream
to uh project development however uh
later uh yesterday overnight uh the the
rapid drop of North stream one pressure
through both of its trunk lines in a
location that happens to be Northeast of
born home uh not directly adjacent to
the Nordstrom 2 site really you know
hits home that that it very likely
um is is some sort of man-made
um uh incident and and this really
raises the stakes in a a completely new
and different way uh but not a way that
was completely unforeseen uh there were
reports that are coming out that the U.S
intelligence agency the CIA actually
warned Berlin about this potential over
the summer again those are reported by
Spiegel so so what man-made but
deliberate and who might benefit from
sabotaging two non-operational Pipelines
well what
number of reasons that one can think of
for the Russian Federation to do this uh
there was uh some uh some speculation in
Target Spiegel yesterday that
um that you know this could be a way for
Russia to create what would be
considered a false flag operation in
other words to try to blame this either
on Ukraine or Ukrainian partisans uh on
the west on the United States on Poland
on Germany uh you name it NATO
um and and basically to churn up
uncertainty uh it also would create
uncertainty uh in in the markets as well
but also have that political uncertainty
to try to reduce the solidarity that the
West has with Ukraine
um but at the same time there's another
reason that we can we can look at and
this is tied back to the Siemens gas
turbine sanctions waiver issue that I
just testified before Canadian
Parliament uh on just a few weeks ago
which is to say that Russia already is
saying that should it need to go in and
help repair these pipelines that it it
would have to to have sanctions lifted
technology sanctions lifted on on the
pipelines and on Russia for them to be
able to do so okay just looking at the
the pictures of of these churning Seas
one's wondering why is there still
pressurized gas in these pipelines when
neither is operational
well first of all we have to remember
that that for nordstring 2 let's let's
look at that first North stream 2 was go
undergoing commissioning operations in
the late months of 2021 and early 2022.
so it had reportedly been filled with
what is known as test gas so there's
still methane
um and and was filled uh with that gas
uh the last reporting that I had seen in
the Press uh before Germany took its
decision to revoke certification and U.S
took its decision in the hours before uh
Russia's large-scale Invasion to uh
finally impose mandatory bipartisan
sanctions uh to stop nordstream too so
what you're seeing from the Nordstrom 2
pipe is very likely that test gas
escaping the pipeline from the seabed
into the water column
um which is a major uh concern for um
for for maritime uh traffic uh because
that could actually create uh you know
unstable buoyancy situations in the
water column that could create uh
basically danger at the surface level
for vessels and on North stream one yes
although North stream won for the past
four weeks or so has been cut off uh by
a political decision by Moscow although
blamed on the turbine uh issue over the
uh over the summer uh again this would
be filled with latent gas so the
question is has Russia turned off uh any
pressure that could be going into the
into the pipes to make this catastrophe
even worse and that's not a good answer
that I've been able to get yet okay so
so looking at why this is so important
Europe's um uh fueled security energy
security the winter is coming and we're
going to be spending a lot more time
indoors how has the EU done in reducing
its dependence on Russian oil and gas
it's working as fast as it can fill the
problem is it's very difficult to build
infrastructure to increase that uh
direct one-to-one hydrocarbon swap uh so
natural gas for natural gas uh you know
Russia for uh swapping out Russia for uh
Global Market LNG as quickly as possible
there's there's development of uh
floating surgery gasification units
going on across the Baltic Coastline in
particular uh in Germany but with these
uh you know unexpected incidents
um you have a situation where Russia is
now already threatening to cut off gas
through Ukraine and may try to use that
to leverage and undermine Western
solidarity on not only the technology
sanctions that I talked about earlier
but also on Western support for Ukraine
trying to get to a ceasefire for uh
Putin to basically reload and and get
through all of uh his recruitment of 300
000 troops and and rebuild to to take
another run at Ukraine and we can't let
that happen
as ever a pleasure talking to you uh Ben
almost very clear a former State
Department of European energy security
advisor Benjamin Schmidt thank you
thanks so much Phil
well data from the Swedish seismological
Network indicates that two underwater
explosions occurred before the pipeline
leaks the Network's director Bjorn Lund
talked me through the findings
yes we detected two blasts yesterday one
early in the morning between Sunday and
Monday at 2 A.M and then a second one
later in the day at 7 00 PM in the
evening and the first blast occurred
south east of the Danish island of
bornholm whereas the second one which is
slightly larger and occurred to the
northeast of bornholm and very close to
the location where the Swedish Maritime
Administration tells us that these gas
leakages or the gases is leaking out of
the pipeline
and could these explosions have been the
result of some naturally occurring
seismological event
no these are not earthquakes and they
are not underwater landslides so these
are definitely blasts and we can see
that both from evaluating the waveforms
um earthquakes do create slightly
different seismic waves than blasts do
in this case it's in the water which
makes the differences even larger and
finally we have data on blasts in
Swedish Waters from the Swedish Navy
where they tell us in advance that they
will be blasting so we're pretty sure
that these are not any natural
phenomenon but definitely blasts and and
do you think these blasts are the cause
or the effects do you think these blasts
cause the holes in the the pipelines or
perhaps an explosion in the pipeline
cause a blast if you see what I'm
driving out there
right right now we have no data uh to
tell you know which is the first and
which comes second we are looking into
the data that we have especially from
the second blast which was slightly
larger and comparing that to the blast
data we have from the Swedish Navy
blasts to see if we can spot and need
you know significant differences for
example that would tell us that it would
be a different Source uh but so far
today we have not been able to come up
with you know anything that is
conclusive so these looks very much like
there's a significant amount of
explosives being detonated at the same
time okay no doubt in your mind this was
man-made
that's right okay good talking to you
thank you so much for uh for joining us
so Bjorn Lunt director of the Swedish
seismological Network
thank you
well energy analyst Mikhail uh crudicin
can tell us more about the pipelines
themselves welcome to DW
um what do you think was this sabotage
yes definitely it was sabotage as far as
we understand that the explosions and
raptures in the pipelines occurred
almost same old simultaneously but the
problem is to determine who is to blame
if uh well the investigators raise
pieces of that Pipeline and see that the
holes in the pipes will have
ages pointing downwards inside the pipe
then it was an explosion from outside
made by some maybe a sabotage group or
some under
underwater
equipment which was
um to explode those pipelines or if we
see that the explosions occurred inside
the pipes then it was the gas problem
gasprom could easily send uh well
something which the technicians go
called a pig it's a robot that goes
inside the pipeline and it is very easy
to well Ascend it in the pipe to a
specific point and then had it have it
exploded right because gasparam is
definitely the company that benefits
from the explosions
because that would have been one of my
next questions so how would gas prom
benefit from the these explosions
gas probe has been trying to demonstrate
to the outer world that it is decreasing
the flow of gas to Europe uh well for
because of some technical problems such
as
unsafe turbines and turbines requiring
repairs
well uh uh Siemens the company that
maintains the pipelines proved that it
was not true and now
but but but why does gas problem need a
pretext these uh two um pipelines are
non-operational both have been uh shut
down so if it is gas prom if it is the
Russian State why uh blow up two
pipelines that are not working anyway
they need
explanation they must show that someone
was blowing those pipes and gasprom is
not to bleed because if gasprom will
show us to the world that uh the
decrease or the termination of gas
supply was caused by some Force Major
some well circumstances that are beyond
the will of gasparam then gasprom will
is not going to pay the
for breaking the contracts and having to
deliver the necessary volume of gas
how difficult would it be then to I mean
could a non-stake actor be involved in
this
we do not know yet but it is a very
determined act uh either from our inside
or from outside we do not know yet I
think investigation will show and uh
well the problem is that to repair those
pipelines uh requires well many months
of work
thank you for joining us and explaining
that so clearly energy analyst Mikhail
akrudikin